so when you sit on the cushion in zazen
the assumption is that you're going to
make this kind of pyramid with your
knees and your spine and so you become
very stable okay and you notice that
when you take away the cushion and
you're sitting and say tha I should
still have that pyramid shape to me with
my spine acting as a kind of axis mundi
the center of the earth
okay this axial so if I start doing this
and if I just relax you'll see what will
happen you see what's happening already
my nose is moving away from him you see
that because my center of gravity is
going this way you got that then if I
tilt it the other way do you see you see
this this is very common right you know
and then you just relax and look what's
happening right nose is moving to you
towards did you see that so the way that
people keep their posture like this with
this pelvic tilt is they keep making
micro adjustments like modern aircrafts
do you know they can't fly and so the
wings have to keep adjusting and you
keep making micro adjustments and they
call that stability okay so the same
thing when you're like this you keep
making micro adjustments to keep you
from falling backwards do you understand
so that would not be a pyramid of course
tactically when I'm like this and he
goes to grab the back of my head to pull
me down right he's gonna he's gonna get
me I sit like this and he goes to thrust
he's gonna get me and it takes away one
of the points that you made when you
push on to the pyramid
he should be lifted not to me trying to
make a do you understand that okay so
that's the point you're the you felt the
horror ah if I push harder I'm actually
going to be the one that's exactly what
we're trying to do yeah so your pelvis
is going to come in a little here you
have to watch at the beginning you
should watch what you do with your head
so the crown of your head you know that
if you ever watch children being born
that part that comes out first it's many
religions give it a psychology okay well
we have that in our posture it needs to
be the high point of your of your head
you cannot be the top of a head you see
that do you see that difference so when
I do this if you watch me again I'm
going backwards aren't done just just
wait if I keep relying I got to keep
making micro adjustments to keep myself
there but when I'm here like this you
you'll find that everything is starting
to sink to sink down and I can just I
just relax so in your zazen training
you're gonna find it very hard to relax
if you keep having to make micro
adjustments to hold yourself still so I
have to put that as the top part of my
head to keep my balance then my pelvis
is not like this in a bracing angle but
angled so that I feel I'm neither going
forward nor backwards okay and then
tactically of course my chin is now
tucked you see a lot of Aikido like this
but if you look at fighting arts across
the world there's no fighting hours like
this you're exposing your throat your
chin is leading this
you'll have this you'll have it tuck to
your chin
okay can guys see that and then I'm
weight is going down now here's the
trick when we do this he goes do you see
he got lifted did you feel so you gotta
what you got to watch here and I'm just
here in that position and of course if I
don't lock everything if this is all
soft then I'm not really a pyramid I'm
more like soft-serve ice cream to get it
if you ever push that thing out all of a
sudden you're like oh that looked like
it was balanced but it has no integrity
to it so I have to lock the pyramid in
shape and then when he goes he he moves
Ducey do you guys see that okay now the
problem is when I give you that drill
you start doing you doing like this do
you see that difference i I'm you can
see right here I'm just here
okay so you have to not want to push him
what you have to do is in the face of
his push you just hold your structure
that's where you put your effort
hold your structure so when you feel
this going like that don't correct like
that correct like this do you see that
difference so hold the structure I'm
going to hold it okay let's try
everything that is a little harder he's
a better cultivating tool but the
downside is if it's harder I probably
won't be able to use it okay so this
this drill this drill here allows me to
try to use my bicep and shoulder you see
that and so it's not a very good tool
because it allows so much okay but as I
said this this hand positioning is a
matter of this structuring so I'm going
to take away the hand positioning and I
again I'm going to just do this turn do
you see so you see his knees okay so to
help you does not be so hard he will
incrementally increase the pressure to
allow you time to not want to do that
you've got to calm your mind and you're
just holding the structure and you'll
pick them up okay so stay connected
push and I'm just holding the structure
stay connected you can see okay so now I
can't do the other one but if I'm mushy
and you don't you're you're never going
to get it do you see that let's say you
won't be able to do it so let's play
between these two drills okay so let's
do the first one good got it you see you
should have it right on contact he goes
to touch you goes to touch to the first
row boom you should have it and then
this one he's going to do incrementally
and I'm just gonna hold the structure
and then you have it okay this doesn't
translate to what we are seeing is those
that want to to be straight is you're
like okay okay okay and then there's
like a weakness in here and your pelvis
starts to go right and then okay right
okay so if you'll come over here come on
okay so we're not when I'm doing that
when I'm doing the drill you guys are
trying to relax
do you understand and so this is very
hard to understand in East Asian martial
arts
if someone says relax and we go like
this okay and that's not that's not what
we mean so scoot backwards just hammer
fist me whatever you can see my whole
body shakes right okay and then I'm
going to I'm going to get the the
posture right and so here Here I am on
relaxed you can hear my voice right just
take note of it right and then I'm going
to get the posture and you're not going
to see any changes in my voice so when I
say don't relax right do you understand
that so I think we're better off by
saying we need to figure out this
selective tension or flexion which is
why I call it organization not
relaxation okay and then you have to
train here for a long time to figure out
what the hell that means
okay so when I have my I have my body
you can tell you can see that I have the
benefits of relaxation because there's
no tension do you see that but if you if
he hits me you won't you're not going to
see the same thing so he comes and
you're gonna hit me you can hit me
wherever and I'm just doing this
try forgiving three next why your
partner is gonna face that way because I
you know again you're not going to task
yourself with with it you're gonna keep
cheating means you're not doing the
drill okay so so if you want a pyramid
wouldn't I be able to push you
everywhere
do you understand so you're gonna find
this bracelet oh it's gonna feel really
stupid to you this way okay
so you're gonna you're a pyramid and
you're holding that structure right and
I can feel my knees lining I can feel
enlightened okay you get it I'm you're
trying to drill that way
that's the structure if I can't do that
I'm gonna have a very hard time
vectoring the energy okay so this drill
is in vectoring okay so let's do it with
two hands okay and you're gonna really
push you're gonna knock me over
come on come on okay try it again push
hard push push get your knees down do
whatever it takes
my fart
didn't send up so I'm here and I get to
incrementally find my Center
let's have fun my name is Christie come
on you're behind then okay so here you
go he's pushing and I get to bring it in
until I feel the ground and you're gonna
push it so every still a second lit for
Silla second move out for this and break
you Priscilla let's try it again
so what what you see is every once in a
while they'll get me but the correction
is here not here okay so this is how
your drill is going to be so I need a
good entire but I'm gonna bring it to
where I'm on my Center and stand up so
you can really push then she pushes okay
try it okay so he's here and then I'm
down here
and they're pushing no matter what I do
right and so I'm just here you see how I
went back a little like that so I
correct by home getting back to the
pyramid okay and everything can be
relaxed except for my bushy Center
cannot one I cannot relax money mushi
Center you got it
that that part of my body has to be
let's go to poetic terms swell full not
mushy got it
charged energized okay you got it
spiracle when if when you do the drill
what you're what you're going to see is
that this this happens do you see that
okay oh right okay so instead of put it
in your mind everywhere else
this is where you put your money oh hold
that there
do you understand so he if you watch
he's pushing on my shoulders right here
I am like this he can never stop them no
matter what I do
he's not strong enough by this angle to
ever influence that flexion do you guys
see that
so he's pushing right I'm here look you
see you see his movement here flex hope
you see it go back into him okay so
what's happening this is when you when
you start to get it ready Tristan when
you start to break you don't do that and
you need to do that you need to pull X
that you see here a loose push you guys
push right boom you see that's that's
what I have to bring back okay go
Racing right so we'll go back to two
people okay and I get you to bring him
in right and then I'm going up on flex
flips punch flex flex and I'm not trying
to move him
I'm just relaxed flex relax let's push
hard relax
flex okay that's just my girl
can you try though
once she once if they can okay I want
you to try to lean lean on the guy if
you can and then that way right he's
going to I'm always going to get the
pulse
you see if he if he stands up he and
he's not he's not good he's not really
leaning on I'm doing the drill push I'm
doing the drill but he doesn't have the
structure for it do you see he can't
push me over and go but I'm not seeing
the reaction so you're gonna put this
foot back here and put the other foot
get your face push man that's it okay
then he has some lean and I can get it
but if he can he's just gonna put all of
his weight on you see and I'm here
Jacob so we were doing this kind of
pulsing what I'm trying to do is to get
you out of the lean and the bracing and
what you should be doing you got it so
now I'm going to take that whole scene
hopefully I gained some kinesthetic
awareness of what I'm actually trying to
do and we're going to go back to the the
drill so now I'm holding it I'm not
pulsing it I never let it go out of that
and then she's gonna push and are
deflecting that the whole time oh my you
want to try okay my OB second I'm whole
I'm holding it you got it I'm holding it
you ain't gonna let him get started
because then you'll override him and you
look you become useless so you got to
wait till you feel he's not going
anywhere
and then you will incremental II you
don't want to make a parlor trick out of
it you don't want to make his push
irrelevant you I understand okay so he's
locked it and then mine will go and I
keep it squeeze okay